also achtet wirklich auf seinen status
und interpretiert den so krass wie in
der schule irgendwann scheiß
langweiliges gedicht was wir analysieren
müssen das gut
hey was geht ab netz willkommen beim ein
video und ja ich bin aufgestanden
es ist heute schon mittwoch also das
video muss jetzt in vier stunden
anleihen gehen ich weiß auch nicht ob
ich das schaffe aber eigentlich schon
auf jeden fall ich bin wach geworden
scheiße heute ist mittwoch mussten video
machen
ich war am wochenende auf der bruder von
oder premiere das ist ja der film von
den kies und ich bin halt erst gestern
wieder gekommen auch ziemlich krank ich
weiß nicht ob man das hört aber ist
natürlich ein grund aber kein hindernis
im video zu machen
kein video zu machen so aber leute sorry
ich muss mich in meiner kreativität so
ein bisschen bedeckt teilt diesmal weil
ja ich hatte einen wirklich überhaupt
keine zeit mich für dieses video
vorzubereiten deswegen hab ich darf ja
kaum was ist gut angekommen habe ich
geguckt oder weißt du was machst du doch
einfach mal einen zweiten teil von so
merkst du dass ihr aufsteht da fallen
mir so viele dinge ein können sondern
zweiten teil ausmachen
deswegen gibt zweiten part 2 ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß spiel gar nicht
lange nicht ob also was noch zu dem film
sagen wollte ich finde ich war wirklich
richtig positiv überrascht deswegen
etwas auf ihn überhaupt gibt meines vier
schichten an kann ich wirklich nur
empfehlen also wenn jetzt nicht gerade
über 20 seit oder so kann man doch
wirklich mal rein ich fand in echt gut
ich weiß nicht ob sein leid weil ich
dann in einen rausch kenne aber ich hab
dann ein ok hat jetzt reicht's gefangen
direkt an aber was ihr was was man so
aufgefallen ist also kommentare unter
dem ersten teil leute ihr seid wirklich
so total negativ eingestellt ich meine
ihr müsst auch ein bisschen sich selbst
glauben ich kann bei kommentaren war
paar kommentare lustige kommentare
herausgesucht und ja also wir checken
jetzt kurz die kommentare und dann
fangen wir auch direkt mit den richtigen
themen aber so ein punkt was zum
beispiel wenn ihr euch an schreibt dann
habt ihr schon so gewonnen so und
schreibt dann wenn er hier für mich an
schreibt dann meistens nur weil nach
hausaufgaben frau tut mir schon ein
bisschen leid jetzt hier
[ __ ] it ich habe den einmal
angeschrieben und er hat nicht blockiert
schreibt die katy das auch gut bei
meinem freund war ich nach zwei jahren
freundschaft nicht eingespeist
eine woche später sind wir
zusammengekommen solltest du irgendwas
sagen vielleicht hat er wirklich erst
von dem 1
anderen tag gemerkt dass du was ganz
besonderes bis vier leute wir tun das
jetzt mal zur seite fallen direkt an
sorry dass ich jetzt war ganz
interessant oder also ich fand's cool
kommentare vorzulesen auf jeden fall
fahren wir an den punkt nummer einen
punkt nummer eins ich muss mal wieder
zum freunden spaß also auf jeden fall
punkt nummer eins wenn dir was mit einem
jungen machten ihr so ganz cool findet
und irgendwie hab ich vielleicht schon
hinbekommen so mal alleine was mitmachen
oder ihr habt mir ein land so die
situation früher alleine mit ihm sein
und heutzutage das ist ja leider so
jeder mensch sein handy hat ist
eigentlich auf fast handy sich mein mann
guckt einen daumen drauf ist bei mir
leider auch so ich kann das auch nicht
abstellen ich denke dann meistens gar
nicht ran aber wenn man so eine coole
situation dann mit einem bett oder so
dann guckt man eigentlich nicht drauf
also für mich wäre das jetzt logisch
deswegen wenn der jungen die sich gar
nicht auf sein handy kuppel mit euch
redet und so dann ist das voll gut dann
merkt auf jeden fall yonder is
interested in me das wird die vom punkt
er ist auch selbstverständlich aber
nicht mehr direkt ein gefallen nächster
punkt ist eigentlich auch total
nachvollziehen weil ich meinen sowie
habt ihr zudem kennen gelernt schreibt
zum mit dem wirklich und worin ihr merkt
dass er es wirklich jetzt herz weil also
schon ernst meint wenn er neben dem tag
schon was vor ort sogar geplant mit
freunden und dann so wirklich für euch
gefragt wie das geht heute wenn er
anhalt so umorganisiert versteht ihr so
dass das war halt auch dabei sein kann
es als mädchen oder das sogar was mit
dir also dass er euch halt dabei haben
bild versteht ihr weil ich kann es jetzt
mal so auf mich beziehen klar ich will
jetzt hier wieder nix anderes schiff
wieder im kommen für jede junge so wie
du oder was auf jeden fall wenn ich es
mädchen cool finde halt nicht einfach
nur so freundschaftlich oder so dann
will man die halt auch dabei haben sagt
der rapper schaaf kam einfach raus oder
soja ich sagte zu meinem freundes
bericht fertig ist kann man auch mal
machen wenn man sich so kennenlerne kann
man auch mal seinen freunden ab sagt was
mir auch noch eingefallen ist das ist
jetzt ich kann wirklich nicht sagen ob
das bei reinigungs ist manche sind da
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
zurückhaltend aber snapshot zu tragen
das haben ja wirklich viele wenn man
sich wirklich so durchgehend so richtig
ich will jetzt nicht behindert sagen
weil es ist eigentlich ich sage das war
zwar schon oft so aber halt irgendwie
total automatisch und man denkt ja gar
nicht so einfach es eigentlich dumm wenn
und sowas sagt also einfach total
verblödet das netz wie man aussieht wie
der letzte hier wird schon so zum
beispiel okay
noch einen filter über damit alte
strecke ganz scheint egal ich mache wenn
man sich so ist halt durch den hin- und
herschicken es kann natürlich auch noch
so freundlich gemeint sein aber ich bin
dass es schon immer so ein kleines
anzeigen dafür könnt ihr eure meinung in
die kommentare schreiben dann lege ich
mir dass man durch okay leute kommen zum
letzten punkt der mir dazu ein gefeiert
und zwar wenn ihr mit einem jungen
schreibt zuwachs überhaupt das schon
geklärt läuft euch das ist jetzt
wirklich nicht so eindeutig aber das ist
auch bei jungs so klar bei mädchen
extremer jungs ändern auch in rotz dem
status wenn man irgendwie wen so ihr
wisst schon weil die denken dann auch
das mädchen ließ das und vielleicht
denkt das mädchen sogar irgendwie habe
ich das gefühl die meisten mädchen
kommen dann gar nicht darauf dass es
auch die bezogen ist auf jeden fall an
seinen status ändert so und irgendwas
was halt so wirklich darauf hindeuten
könnte keine ahnung das ist auch
irgendwie schon immer so ein bisschen
ruhe und wenn man als junger so sein
status ändern da war und nicht also
achtet wirklich auf seinen status und
interpretiert in so krass wie in der
schule irgendwann scheiß langweiliges
gedicht was wir analysieren müssen das
gut
ja ich finde dafür dass gerade
aufgestanden habe ich das ziemlich gut
gemacht ist in leipzig gefeiert und die
vielleicht auch im dritten teil das auf
jeden fall noch nach oben da würde mich
sehr freuen ihr könnt doch kein
kommentar schreiben mit eurer meinung
und so dies das ansonsten sind wir uns
sonntag wieder ankommen das nächste
video aber nie vergessen mit
überrissenen slapshot ins normales
angewendet wie oben links geht's weiter
beim ersten eigenen song kann man nur
sagen dass auf jeden fall wenn ich noch
nicht gesehen hat also sehen wir uns
dann wieder bis zum nächsten mal